right we do have a senior advisor with
the prime ministry joining us on the
phone if I'm not mistaken we have Chema
Letson Hasini joining us right now from
Turkey can you sir confirm that this
military coup has been attempted and now
forted or are the struggles ongoing well
we have managed to get the control in
many parts of in many parts so what we
know for sure that faction in the army
and acting outside of the chain of
command so we are sure about a second
thing all of the statements might made
on their behalf unauthorized statements
by the military headquarters as of now
just couple of minutes we have received
latest info a compound in for in in
majority of places they have lost and we
managed to get the control so while this
the situation is critical it's sensitive
and we have to wait at least for 24
hours but what we know for sure the
government and the state all of
legitimately elected or legitimately
elected officials managed to resist
against the military intervention and
one thing the president and the
government are in powers and as of now a
legal process has initiated against
those people both by the armies and by
the prosecutor we can we believe that
yeah we can very much see that the
president is still at large and and
seems to be very safe right now and the
government seems to be holding together
but what about the military the the
chief of Defense hulusi a car has been
reported captured do you know about his
whereabouts and how he is at the moment
I cannot I do not have any specific info
about it but what you can see what
that in the last one our several
high-ranking generals including second
commanding army they made statements
calling all the soldiers outside of
their barracks to go back to the
military barracks and they made it clear
that a legal process will be initiated
against them and they look for
securities so what we know for sure
majority of Army with the exception of
that faction and which has been defined
as by one of the general as a governess
or parallel represented a number of
parallel sub structure with the
exception of them or me is United all
social groups all social groups in
Turkey regardless of their political
position and now our chart for testing
the military intervention and bitterly
in Syria in Ankara Central Georgia
people are climbing over the tanks to
protest intervention so while we are sad
while we are we are we feel all the
difficulties of the situation right now
we are happy - I am happy to say that
Turkish people are doing everything
including all officials and all the to
protect democracy of the gang we will be
success
can I ask you and I just want to remind
our viewers we are talking right now to
a senior advisor at the turkish prime
ministry Chema Lutton Hashimi can I ask
you about reports that Parliament has
been bombed we're hearing or seeing
reports from a Turkish news agency that
Parliament has been bonner that there
were at least explosions there do you
know it's not a bomb it's what we call I
don't think you can leave it's something
called just to create fear but we do not
have any difficulty in the Parliament we
have some difficulty around the
Parliament but number of Parliament are
now over there already
couple of opposition parties has have
made a statement that they are
criticizing their and endorsing
democracy and they will drive a simple
assist the custom is to intervention
so it's not a bump mr. Sami tell us
about the support of the military
outside of Istanbul and Ankara it's been
hugely fluid since the coup of 1980 the
recent ecoo and all of a number of years
ago what is the support of the military
away from the elites in Istanbul and
Ankara well one of the things that
characterized this attempt of
overthrowing democratically elected
government is that this group is acting
outside of the chain of command they are
definitely a small group but well
organized what organized group but what
we are sure also with the exception of
some places in Ankara and some places in
Istanbul we do not have any difficulty
in terms of security in none in any of
the speed of Turkey so in almost all
parts of Turkey the situation is under
control by pro-democracy forces how will
the government adapt to this first of
all I believe Matt asked you this but
I've got to answer a question
where is mr. Erdogan right now yeah the
president is in Istanbul right now well
I mean it's easy Ankara and a couple of
hours just even 45 minutes right after
the first news about inter military
intervention they make their statements
Prime Minister went on tear and he has
the paid that the government is in power
and we will prosecute and they will pay
the price involved with the attempt the
president is in Istanbul and also he has
called people to come out and protest
the intervention and I see people on TV
right now thousands of them with Turkish
flags are protesting and there are
leftist groups there are conservative
groups there are Kurdish groups less
youth groups they are all carrying
Turkish flags protesting the military
intervention which shows maturity of
Turkish democracy which shows the
results of people regardless of their
fall color creation was the Sun I was
take it so what I can see is that look
we have been target and subjective for
military intervention but we will resist
one do you wanna just this one and we
will be structure do you know can I ask
if you have any idea of who has started
this coup who is responsible for this
you tell you're telling us that some of
the top generals have been gathered
together there are Turkish newspaper
reports from mil yet for example that
this could be a coup started by a
colonel Newham cosa do you know any of
those details I do not have any of these
because we have to wait for confirm
people we ask for at least 24 hours
actually so we know it's a small faction
in the army doesn't that small fraction
when do you think let me go ahead and
remind viewers again we're talking with
scheme' lesson how see me he is a senior
advisor to the turkish prime ministry
joining us on the phone from turkey when
do you think we will get the the the
small military faction cleared out from
Istanbul and Ankara and when do you
think you'll be able to gain control
full control of the streets there
majority of police is including some
Blanca in Majorca suppose it's already
under control
particularly the one at the National
Intelligence task force because there
have been at attacks over there and also
at the military headquarters majority of
those places have been undertaken under
control but I believe 20 in 24 hours we
will take full control sure know whether
you wrote a book in 2011 and edited a
book on Turkey Europe in the European
Union very quickly here how will this
could change the immediate dialogue
between turkey in the European Union
well as of now we urge all our allies
and all the world leaders to stand in
solidarity with Turkish people and
Turkish democracy it is time for
European Union to declare support which
I have something for that statement so
to stand to the third instance with the
Turkish democracy and Turkish people as
an impact I believe
that as a country who with people which
is politicians which is the leaders with
army and all other officials managed to
resist against the major intervention
it's a sign of success of Turkish
democracy or that maturity of such
democracy we will be able to we will we
will be able to protect Turkish dignity
of Turkish democracy and I hope that all
of our allies will stand in Turkey and
the impact we will see we will see but
what we know our relationship with
European Union and which you asked and
also Allah is right all of its impact
okay Semillon I see me thank you so much
and of course speaking with his
experience with the present Turkish
government